so my stance feels good but I'm still
not hitting center all right back your
left foot up a hair like this no Gina
we've been over this well show me like
wrap your thick muscular arms around me
all right look
everybody go home sleep it off I'm sorry
thank you
ultimately it was our raw sexual
chemistry that helped him overcome his
crippling fear you should just stay in
the office all day every day and be my
bestie you can join my dance troupe
floorgasm we're looking for a man afraid
it's gonna be a long road but I'm ready
to get myself back in the game I know
you will I mean eventually not tonight
you need to go hug my girls hey I've
been looking for you We Need to Talk can
we not do this right now Terry I'm in
the midst of a personal tragedy oh my
god is everything okay with your family
family what no this is serious floorgasm
just came by and danced me out of the
group
[Applause]
it's not fair I founded the group and
now they want to kick me out just
because I missed eight rehearsals in a
row I never thought I'd say this
floorgasm has a point you're being super
irresponsible you have AB attitude
that's a bad attitude oh look I didn't
want you to know because it's so
off-brand for me but I'm missing
rehearsals because I've been going to
college at night I'm trying to finish my
bachelor's degree or whatever really
that's great Gina I'm so proud of you
and while I generally nail everything
I'm just having trouble balancing my
studies and my passion for dance unless
you're working full time yeah that
actually doesn't factor into it
whatsoever anyway it doesn't matter
because I'm never gonna dance again the
world just lost an angel you know what
I'm gonna dance with you tonight you I'm
not gonna let those losers punish you
for doing something good school is cool
that's why it rhymes Terry you are the
best world your angel has returned
[Music]
Hey don't look so sad floorgasm is just
a wetter let's dance ship without you
already gone with flock of dum-dums I'll
talk to the captain we're all gonna
pitch in and help you manage your time
so you can pursue dance and school and
I'd like to volunteer my time to tutor
you for free mmm I heard pass on that
but I do want to thank you guys for
being so understanding and nice now get
your game face on large it's time to
dance if you forget your moves just rip
your cape off and throw me up in the air
like a pizza put your hands together for
the dance duo mr. and mrs. Terry
Jeffords I did not agree to that name
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everybody in my hands I hold the
driving directions to this year's
detectives only get away give it a cool
name Jake
all right detectives only get away do G
dog dog party dog party 15 whoo foo foo
big shout-out to Charles Boyle for
hosting us at his beach house this year
yeah you should really think my ex-wife
if we split it in the divorce I get it
for December through February winter
b-house whoa
yes gnarly catching on as always there
will be no spouses no bosses no work no
bedtimes within reason
all right Santiago's feeling rowdy who
else is feeling it I can't wait this
weekend I am vacation Terry no kids no
responsibilities I'm just a balloon
floating in the great blue sky and I am
untethered and just to clarify how
untethered is vacation Terry from his
wife very tether Gina great news oh no
is Neil deGrasse Tyson here he will not
stop trying to friend me no but we think
we figured out how you're going to pass
your test yeah we realized that we were
trying to get you to learn using our
methods we should have been speaking
your language the language oh damn 13.8
billion years ago
there was nothing and end up yeah Amy
back up till you feel the wall and Terry
ditch the shirt I'm ready to learn
and that's how you calculate parallax
distance so you ready for the test oh I
took it this morning I passed but it was
made so much you guys cared so I
actually opened up my textbook for the
first time y'all astronomy is kind of
interesting and I am hella smart why'd
you make us do that old dance two
reasons
uno and s how you died one two one two
one two one okay so I talked to captain
hope he and Jake have the mumps I'm in
charge until Holt gets better hello
you wanted to see if you could make a
great captain now's your chance to shine
you're the pretty little understudy and
the aging lead well she just fell down
the stairs now all you got to do is beat
those wings fly so for the next two
weeks captain Holt will be a medical
leave which means I am the acting
captain and we are your royal subjects
do continue I want this precinct to get
our normal work done but also we're
gonna clean out the evidence room step
up community service and complete these
22 additional tasks every time we check
one off the list you're gonna hear this
Bell it's the sound of victory hmm you
should have fixed bail to that list
alright alright looks good
I can barely tell you hulked out in here
yeah but two weeks in charge and I
didn't get any of my goals accomplished
you got Hitchcock and Scully off their
hunger strike I just threw a bunch of
popcorn on the floor when that on yeah
they're animals do you want to know why
the amazing captain Holt has never
gotten the evidence room cleaned or done
anything on your list
what because all day long he's putting
out fires that's what a captain does hmm
the only difference between you and Holt
is that he lacks the strength to close a
door so hard a room blows oh thanks Gina
ah you don't have to thank me all I did
was be the only person who believes in
you don't lean against the door Terry
cause structural damage my god you're
strong you're going down oh he's exact
weight for no reason Stevi shillings you
have the right to remain loser noise but
now legally I have to start over Charles
hope your daughter helps with neck pain
it's just an outfit I need paint I made
it up I got your farm girl dude wouldn't
Terry got his computer back
going on here oh yeah you guys doing
Bolger has I mean someone had a good
time in Paris Oh Kevin and I shared a
perfect week together I feel like I'm
floating on a song I wonder why people
don't just break in a song more often
I've been asking you for months if I
could answer the phone like give it a
whirl girl
guys he's rhyming he's telling Gina to
sing captain Holt is on a vacation hi
he will say yes to anything right now I
would like a police horse and I'd like
Terry to be riding it almost constantly
I like an HR person to remind everyone
about workplace boundaries set Sarge
just digging through the garbage like a
normal person I'm trying to find out who
our leak is what makes you so sure that
there's a leak it might have just been
that the reporter was really good at his
job like that hot blonde surfer was at
TMZ maybe you leak their excuse me I'm
gonna say you did it on purpose maybe
you left the file on the subway I mean
you don't take your job very seriously
whoa we're about to have our first fight
as a couple Terrance first of all I take
my job very seriously that's why I'm
here right now helping you and I'm the
only one doing it or I was until you
insulted me now watch me walk away
I said watch me what's going on Sarge
you find that leak yet
yes I'm hiding behind a coffee maker
spying on everyone in this office
because I found the leak Wow
sarcasm is not a good look on you
you